[Music]
hey y'all
it's monday it's kind of like dark in
here i mean it's always dark in here but
i think it's like it's what's raining
outside it's raining outside so it's
darker than usual it's not coming in
through the little slats yeah which is
kind of nice actually but it seems like
it's way later than it is
so in case you guys didn't see my
announcement earlier i did announce it
on the youtube community tab and i
announced it on the facebook page we're
just gonna go straight 5 p.m eastern
standard time for all the live streams
uh just so people aren't confused about
because you know i don't even know why
we started doing it at three o'clock and
some of them at five that didn't make
any sense it didn't really make any
sense um so honestly it seems like
easier for everybody to remember yeah uh
just doing them all at five so basically
we'll just live stream like pretty much
every day at five except for thursdays
and saturdays yeah so whatever it is
whether it's movie review or whatever so
if you didn't see that announcement
that's what we're doing from now and
that's why
uh we're like
on here right now inside at three
o'clock
so as we mentioned yesterday uh we've
gotten into a little we were in a burt
reynolds thing and now we're in a
charles bronson thing yeah well that's
what they're showing for free
i know so like i said we just kind of
therefore we just kind of like wander
around like watch whatever watch
whatever is available for youtube and
putting free charles bronson up
yeah for one called the assassination
that they put that up today yeah so
we're doing this one today and then
tomorrow we're gonna do mr majestic
because we watched that one last night
which actually i had seen when i was a
kid i thought i had seen this one too
but if i did i didn't remember it this
came out in 1972 mechanic now new uh mr
majestic's up there for free that's good
too it's kind of like a neo western with
kind of like a western type farmer in
california dealing with them mafia
assassins it's pretty good in the 70s
yeah i think that i can't remember what
uh what year that one was but yeah so
this one
uh interestingly i didn't know and a
couple people have brought this up they
actually did a remake of this movie
in 2011
with jason statham i didn't see it uh i
have not seen it either uh i went and
read the wikipedia synopsis it sounds
kind of similar not exactly similar but
it's kind of like the same thing about
you know an assassin whose whole thing
is to kind of like make the [ __ ] look
like accidents yeah like he's not just
like plugging people from you know he's
not going the easy way he always has to
make everything look like plausible
deniability type of thing yeah you're
kind of artistic about it which to me
yeah to me like makes it more
interesting because honestly the opening
sequence of this
uh charles bronson doesn't actually talk
all that he does but he doesn't really
talk all that much particularly in the
first act of the film yeah that's good
yeah so for the first like 15 minutes of
this you're just basically seeing him
doing a hit yeah and he doesn't say
anything so you're just kind of like and
you're sitting there the whole time like
you know he's gonna he's rubbing out
this dude but you're not entirely sure
how it's gonna happen what it is that
he's doing yeah because he like breaks
into he's watching the guy from across
the thing and he's like breaking into
the dude's apartment
and then pictures of things taking
pictures of all his [ __ ] in his
apartment
like where it's at and everything he
goes out there and makes a gas leak and
puts a damn little [ __ ] igniter in a
book and shoots it with a pellet gun
[ __ ] blows a dude up you put it he
put some some sedatives in his teeth too
did a bunch of cool [ __ ] yeah so he'd
fall asleep and he wouldn't be able to
wake up because yeah because i was like
well obviously he's causing a gas leak i
got that but then i was like why is he
poisoning the tee though that seems like
overkill but then it was yeah it was
because it was a sedative that he put in
the tea so that he would be asleep and
he wouldn't be able to be like oh no
that's you know there's a gas leak so i
guess it's a good idea because you know
you're getting paid to knock these dudes
off and it looks like accidents
so they don't so the police don't look
too much into it and there's no heat
that's what i mean it seems much to be
honest yeah uh you know if i was in the
mob that's what you'd want which i'm not
yeah you would or as far as you guys
know but i mean you would think that
that would be the way to go about it
yeah to me it seems much easier and i
think like even the younger guy who's
played by uh jan michael john michael
vincent is it young or jan
um what well usually it's jan if you're
yeah
like that but that's right from
california
yeah but it's
i don't know but um
and you were right it was airwolf he
wasn't airwolf i was confusing him with
somebody else with their names but uh
yeah so what was i even saying oh okay
so he even says
you know when he's kind of like in
training and stuff he's just kind of
like yeah like pushing a [ __ ]
out a window or something like i was
like exactly like why don't we see
more movies
about assassins who make [ __ ] look like
accidents because to me that just seems
like it would be way
better it would keep because obviously
if you just like i said if you just plug
a dude from across the [ __ ] thing
obviously that's a murder
you know yeah so it just seems like much
easier to just yeah just blow up his
apartment oh my god it was a gas leak it
was a terrible accident you know what i
mean it's just i don't know it just
seems like much better to me so i really
like that they uh explored that in this
movie
because you don't really see much of
that usually a hit man yeah it's
somebody that's just like shoots people
from windows and stuff
which to me seems less realistic yeah
all right so well no i'm just saying
it was it's it's a this is a pretty good
movie it's like uh it surprised me i
thought it was going to be kind of like
a shallow shoot em up type of a movie
it's not it's got a lot of uh
psychological drama in it it's got some
weird uh pretty good camera angles the
uh
the the score is good the story's real
good the acting isn't always that good
but then sometimes you find out that
there's a reason why the acting isn't
that good it's not that good because the
person's not a good actor
like the person is playing a role in the
movie and they're not that good yeah the
one scene that you're talking about
is the scene with jill ireland you
please correct me if i'm wrong but was
not jill ireland i think she was married
to charles bronson at this point or am i
just like completely talking out my ass
right now
i thought they were married at some
point but there's one scene where he
goes to her apartment
and tom's watching the scene going is
she just like a really shitty actress or
what the [ __ ] is going on here yeah and
um cause she's like acting like his
girlfriend oh i wrote you a love letter
and she's like reading it to him and
it's like super cringe yeah and you know
he's like wow she's a terrible actress
but then it turns out that she's a
prostitute yeah and he pays her to
pretend like that's pretend a certain
way like she's
really into him and she's his girlfriend
and she's written him all these letters
and missed him and stuff like that
because the whole point of his character
is he's this very stoic
supposedly mostly emotionless sort of
like killing machine
yeah i can't the way i kind of took it
is that he's a serial killer
yeah he's actually a serial killer
because he's got a real abuse of
childhood uh
he's kind of raised by gangsters i think
he's a little bit autistic
um i think um
uh i think he's gay
i just well you know what's interesting
about that although i will say that i
don't think he's a complete sociopath
because there are little hints in there
that he is kind of like because he has
that stress ball like that wax thing
that he's always like [ __ ] with and
he's having kind of like some sort of
problems yeah so he does have but
interestingly it's interesting you say
that because we did
when we were watching the movie
you were kind of like you know picking
up on a lot of like gay subtext and i
said yeah i see that but it's like that
they didn't really do anything with it
in the movie though like they didn't
bring it up yeah interestingly though i
looked up on the wikipedia page the
original screenplay yes i knew it was
going to be
the two guys it was supposed to be like
explicitly gay that's what i figured but
this was 1972
and they said uh no producers they
couldn't get any funding for the movie
with that and a lot of the actors uh
that they considered for it like george
c scott like was like absolutely not i'm
not doing any of that gay [ __ ] yeah um
so they took it out and michael winner
who was the director he also did the
death wish movies and he did the
sentinel that really good like uh horror
movie uh he was like really disappointed
because he said well
he's like i liked the whole
psychological angle of this older
assassin like training this younger one
but he's like i also wanted there to be
this extra layer of
sexual manipulation
like there was in the original
screenplay but they made him take most
of it out yeah although
i figured that they made him take it out
because they wouldn't uh because there's
a lot of [ __ ] that kind of goes down
this movie kind of sounds like something
that that homosexual serial killers
instead [ __ ] would do and fantasize
about because in a way
some weird stuff
he hooks up
or he's working for this one guy who's
hiring him to kill a bunch of people in
this organization
and he meets his bosses
or one of his clients son
yeah there's an eye contact scene there
he goes man that's some gay eye contact
it says that they're looking at each
other i said did you see that jenny
she's like no and i said no well no i
did but then i was like well i didn't
know if they were gonna do anything and
then they didn't do anything with it
because the thing that i thought was
like well i kind of figured this is
1972. i was like i didn't think charles
bronson would be in anything that had
any kind of like homosexual subtext to
it so i was just kind of like but i did
i was like yeah i see what you're saying
so i was kind of like i was like let me
see if they do anything with that right
um it's pretty low-key but like i said
it was very explicit in the original
screenplay and then
and then charles bronson gets a mission
to kill
that dude he's there's definitely like
some [ __ ] going on between them too
they're even traveling around going to
[ __ ] funerals and well goes okay then
bronson kills that dude's dad and they
go to the film they go to the funeral
together and and the [ __ ] the kid is
like yeah [ __ ] that dude i got all this
[ __ ] now
he doesn't care
yeah and then and and [ __ ] bronson
didn't tell him that he killed his dad
yeah he doesn't find out until later
connor becomes his dad in a certain way
or at least he thinks he is
and then they go to to to to
to the jan michael vincent to his
girlfriend's house
and he helps the girlfriend try to kill
herself and the motherfucker's ruthless
well she says she's going to kill
herself and he's just kind of like yeah
whatever go ahead do it i'll be over
there and he him and charles bronson
just like watch there and watch her yeah
and then then he kind of shamed her when
she didn't know okay you got about an
hour go ahead here go back go to the
house here go to the hospital and i'm
going like okay
so i took that as gay too
you know what i mean he's giving up the
woman and he's joining up they're
bonding together over
sacrificing the girlfriends he
sacrifices his
his dad and his girlfriend
and then all of a sudden they're a team
now
you know and i i i and every time
they're [ __ ] showing each other it's
got jam michael vince's damn crotch
in the [ __ ] well they do introduce
him with a crotch yeah and then and then
and then he's talking to bronson and you
just see bronson behind his crotch like
his cabra you know the angles you know
it's all about it's like basically what
they're trying to tell you is that
[ __ ] bronson he's under the control
of that dick that dick's controlling him
well see michael winner
might have been mad because he was mad
there was like a quote uh on the web
on wikipedia where he said i really wish
we could have explored that because i
wanted to add that extra layer of sexual
manipulation
um but he so he was mad that they took
that out so he might have shot it he
might have shot it like to
you know if you weren't really looking
for it you know maybe it wouldn't but if
there was like a subtext in there i
picked up on it
uh but yeah so symbolism the symbolism
and all the ant
in the camera angles and all the [ __ ]
the way they were looking at each other
and that kind of made me wonder because
i haven't seen the remake with jason
statham yeah and i'm kind of like from
what i could glean from what i read
about it like i read the plot synopsis
and a couple reviews of it and stuff i i
think that they took that angle out
entirely in the remake it seems like and
i'm not sure i haven't seen it so i
could be totally wrong but it seems like
they went
way more like in a straight-up
father-son type dynamic rather
than maybe couples yeah well i mean
because i mean charles bronson was quite
a bit older than you know all that well
not that much older i guess because
charles brought it to 20 years yeah it
was you know something like that and uh
jen michael vincent wasn't i mean he was
young but he wasn't like weird young or
anything early 30s
yeah so the thing about it is that yeah
you were supposed to like see this
connection between them because
uh charles bronson's character whose
name is uh bishop by the way that's his
last name
and he recognizes in this younger kid
this same kind of like sociopathy i
guess he's like yeah he'd probably be
really good at this yeah because he
doesn't really seem to give a [ __ ] about
anything and he's really he was really
smart and he was like a quick learner
and he's kind of like figuring out hey
you know all these different ways that
you could go around killing these people
that because what they would do is they
would get a call or they would get a
package in the mail like a box and it
would have all this information about
whoever the target was and then they
would study the target and they're just
kind of like okay well what's the best
way to go about this to make it look
like an accident
and
then so they would spend a few days
doing that and then they would get the
phone call that says okay go ahead with
it at your discretion so i guess that he
had
uh you know charles bronson had
apparently been working for this uh
organization for a long time and was
like the best one they had so they kind
of left it to him
how he wanted how he best wanted to
approach it to again like make it look
like plausible deniability make it look
like an accident like when he killed uh
the guy's dad the kid's dad keenan
nguyen
uh was who played him when he killed him
he basically set it up so
he shot at the dude but he made it look
like or he made it seem like a sniper
was shooting at him and that he was
trying to help him and then he made him
like run around and like because he knew
he had a weak heart and uh so he was
sure he was trying to like get him to
have a heart attack like by freaking him
out so he so he would do [ __ ] like that
so like i said i really liked i don't
know i just really liked that angle of
them trying to like figure out
what's the best way to kill this person
without
you know
attracting anything i thought that was
just more of a sideshow angle to it
though i mean that that was cool what i
what i thought was weird was just the
grooming aspect yeah that too okay more
like the group grooming this guy to be a
be a replacement for him this
replacement assassin
but then um
and it's kind of like a pet project that
turns out that the greater organization
finds out about it and they're like so
you brought him on as a replacement for
you without or like a or like an
assistant without asking about asking us
and
and are like that's so
they i believe they get put him on a
mission to kill to kill him
didn't he take it
well
well the thing about it he did have a
mission i think because he did have one
of those boxes but i think it turned out
later
that he hadn't actually got the phone
call saying to kill him he was just
doing it for funsies right
anyway these two assassins they were in
this uh relationship they don't really
spell it out in the movie but you know i
picked up on it uh they decided that it
should have been there
i i agree well the director uh would it
would have agreed with you yeah because
he really was
pissed that they took that out the movie
would have been a lot better
the seven the 70s i guess weren't you
would think the 70s would be ready for
that because there was already a creepy
[ __ ] it was kind of like
that damn serial killer who was [ __ ]
capturing them kids and
making them fight each other to death on
that board what was that guy's name who
was that dean coral dean coral yeah this
is like some dean coral type [ __ ] uh
although he's not he's not sexual sadist
but they're just [ __ ] killers you
know and dean yeah just like
cold-blooded yeah and dean coral picked
up a damn assistant and then in the end
they [ __ ] turned on each other but uh
it's kind of like that yeah so it was
kind of similar to something yeah yeah
so it was kind of like a serial killer
type situation because man these two
were [ __ ] cold-blooded man yeah the
one scene where his girlfriend calls and
says i'm gonna kill myself or whatever
and he's just like yeah i would ever do
it and um so then they go over there
like him and charles bronson go over
there and she's like has this whole
thing set up yeah um
you know and she just like slices her
wrists and like just sits there and
there and he's asking how long do you
think it'll take her to like bleed to
death and uh charles bronson's like how
much do you weigh yeah he knew
everything and she says and he's like oh
probably about three and a half four
hours yeah so they just kind of like sit
there and watch her yeah
and i was just like god damn that's some
cold blooded sheriff yeah
and and uh [ __ ] bishop is just
judging whether or not this kid is
actually if he's just [ __ ] around if
he's really gonna do it yeah it was
almost like a test he was gonna do it
and then um but no it's a good movie
it's got a lot of little psychological
angles in it and it's kind of true to
life there there was people doing this
kind of stuff
and that that that gay element should
have been in there i agree with it
because the movie makes so much more
sense with that in there well and like i
said it adds a whole other level
it adds a whole other layer of like
psychological fire because bishop
the bishop character is like a super
individualist kind of like outsider he's
living in a secret underworld of these
[ __ ] assassins and [ __ ]
and he's far outside society he talks
about being above all of this and you
have to step outside of it or just
talking about society in the world and
everything to see how
to knock somebody off
or how to get a mission done you can't
be
emotional about it uh uh or at least
when you're doing the planning phase
so uh all that [ __ ] is coming so he was
stepping outside himself he'd step
outside of the world outside of society
outside of his depths gender i guess or
whatever outside of what society's
expectations were
just like a true
he's gonna do it his own way he didn't
care he didn't care what other people
thought
yeah he really did live in this kind of
like and it's interesting too because he
obviously uh was was okay for money like
he looked yeah he's rich yeah like he
looked like he was rich
so yeah he had this big house he was
very into very hannibal lecter in the
sense that he was very into like
classical music and and art and like
wine collections yeah and his house was
all [ __ ] fantastic yeah decorated and
he had all kinds of like he was big into
like uh attila the hun and [ __ ] you
know warlords of the past and medieval
stuff inside the house of weaponry and
[ __ ] so
he was i guess you could say he was kind
of like he was a [ __ ] man's man you
know [ __ ] very warrior [ __ ] um
oriented and uh he was gonna he was
gonna be [ __ ] whoever he wanted [ __ ]
you know and he was into this other guy
and was gonna turn him into an assassin
like him and they were just
in their own little
universe
and um
yeah it's just a good story man it makes
a lot more sense when you're looking at
the story from that angle as soon as i
saw him make the eye contact the way
that was shot i knew what the director
was trying to tell me so i saw it like
that through the whole but like i said
he really had to like keep it on the
deal yeah i guess because i i understood
what the director is trying which is
weird because like you said in the 70s i
kind of feel like though although i
don't know it's kind of hard to say
there was like some openly gay
characters in the 70s but i feel like
1972 they were still used as kind of
like comic relief type characters
or yeah or something like that yeah um
so i don't know necessarily they didn't
want to show any other aspects outside
that
you're not a man there and i'm i'm not
really sure if charles bronson would
have agreed to be in it if that had
still been in there they didn't say
anything about that on the wikipedia
page but they said that like
that george c scott was one of the
actors that they considered at first and
he said that he wouldn't do that i'm
sure he knew okay yeah i think what it
was there was a compromise there wasn't
going to be any explicit discussion of
it but the but it's it's there
it's there it's just not it's just not
discussed but
it it it's it's just demonstrated in the
camera angles
and [ __ ] how they're reacting to each
other but it's just not disgusting you
can interpret it either way
yeah but if you understand film and how
directors and [ __ ] a good director how
he shoots things i know exactly what it
was which again he's sitting there
talking to [ __ ] bishop and they're
showing the camera shot from [ __ ] his
crotch angle and bishop far away yeah
like sitting on the patio yeah i'm
coming like like
you know what's controlling him type of
deal you know or what he's trying to
control him with it's just it was sexual
in
connotations
but like i said it's not explicit it's
just well i'm sure they i'm sure michael
winner wanted to leave some of that in
there and then but if somebody called
him on it he'd be like what
uh yeah you guys dirty mind
yes that just must be you thinking it
and i didn't put that in there [ __ ]
um i think that i i think i think
bronson knew i think he knew and i think
he i think he would agree with me and
the director that that's what that
should have been i really liked him in
this role to be honest i thought he was
really really good in it and i really
liked like i said i liked the whole
first part of it where he didn't even
talk but it was still like really really
like riveting yeah with that angle it
makes a movie
more alien
it does because there's no other movie
like this and there there isn't a
character that i can think of that's
like that
not in any kind of action movie yeah he
was really like a fascinating character
for being like so stoic right and so
cold-blooded and like reptilian a little
bit although like i said they're
artistic a little bit there were some
hints though that he was bothered by it
like i said because there was that whole
like that wax ball like a stress ball
they didn't have stress balls back then
but it was the same principle
um you know and [ __ ] like that so there
was kind of like
hints that there were like cracks
appearing in his armor i guess uh but
again that was kept very subtle
zach says i've never heard of this movie
but it sounds super similar to a script
i wrote a few years ago and now i'm kind
of creeped out yeah go see it it's for
free on youtube yeah you can watch it
for free on youtube
they remade it as i mentioned in 2011
with jason statham yeah uh and
it sounds fairly similar like i said it
uh you know they changed up the way they
killed people and everything but
i
the reviews that i read but i just read
a couple reviews and most people said
it's fine as like action type movies go
but it's like this movie didn't really
need to be remade yeah um but the remake
was actually so successful that they
ended up doing a sequel to it in 2016
called the mechanic resurrection yeah um
because so i'm guessing that the remake
didn't end the same way that this movie
did yeah because i'm not really sure how
they would make a sequel to the first
jack you'd like this movie the tone
the tone is not your average 70s action
movie it's got a lot of 70s action in it
but the tone of the movie is very eerie
it's very eerie yeah it's very good it's
very much what you're dealing with is
dean coral
and dean coral going out killing people
and then he meets up with this younger
guy and they're killing these people
together and there's a lot of undertones
and [ __ ] and then eventually they turn
on each other and it's just got a creepy
vibe to it they're both perverts
basically they both are not so much of
sex sexuality it's just that they get
off on killing people yeah you know
and you'll see it's good
um and yeah mike barrett's bringing up
10 to midnight actually i want to do
that eventually too because i remember
really liking that movie uh let's see
oh in england said have you seen the
remake uh remake is just a generic
action yeah that's yeah that's kind of
what i figured i mean yeah all the
reviews said you know it's fine it's
just
there's nothing real you know compelling
about it see this one this one this
one's a masterpiece of what of of what
it is it's not perfect it has some rough
spots in it but no i got it it's a good
movie i would say it kind of reminds me
in a certain way remember the remember
the professional
yeah you have the kind of kind of the
slow dude with the [ __ ] little young
girl yeah yeah
that's also kind of hinting that he's
sleeping with that younger girl that
it's yeah i got that vibe too you know
what i mean
they can't it's not explicitly spoken of
but you assume that that must be what's
going on but i mean it is a little weird
for like a grown man to like be
wagging around like a little girl that's
not his daughter yeah like teaching her
how to deal yeah and he kind of got her
because the her family got wiped out by
some gangsters so he just takes her in
yeah zack says it's kind of sad how only
in the last decade there's been any
interesting gay themed movies that
aren't totally tragic
yeah it does seem like honestly even up
until [ __ ] man i kind of i want to say
like up until the 90s or even the early
2000s like it seemed like if you had a
gay character they always had something
bad too this is not a gay themed movie
though no it's not but that but it's
definitely the subject it has a subtext
but that's not what the movie's about
movies about these [ __ ] psychos yeah
yeah
and they're kind of like yeah and
they're interesting though they're
[ __ ] psychos but they're empty yeah i
mean that's the thing about it and it
showed to you in a 70s format which is
weird to see it in the 70s context
yeah yeah yeah it's like you know like i
said i thought i had seen this movie
back in the day but i don't think i did
like i said i did see a lot of charles
bronson movies a long time ago this is
one of his best ones i've seen so far
yeah same i really i really dug this one
i really dug this one like i said i
really liked it was good but this one is
very special
yeah i mean yeah we're going to talk
about mr majestic tomorrow because we
watched that one last night i think i
liked this one slightly better just
because it was
darker weirder weirder like the whole
psychology was like was a lot more
fascinating
whereas you know mr majestic was kind of
just more like a straightforward yeah it
was more straightforward i got
neo-western yeah whereas the mechanic
was kind of more like i said it delved
into like darker psychological kind of
yeah serial killer type [ __ ] yeah john
goris this movie made me gay
[Laughter]
look man you guys see this movie you'll
see what i'm talking about it's not
explicitly stated but the movie doesn't
mean it's not as good without that text
not that without that sub that subtext
makes the movie make a makes it make a
lot more sense
it makes a lot more sense and it's
weirder
that these dudes are
were were a thing
but now they're going to kill each other
yeah and they know it it's [ __ ] it at
first he's kind of like hey this is this
is my little like assistant and he's you
know isn't he awesome like i'm teaching
him all this stuff and he's really good
at it and then they start like turning
on one yeah and then there's like this
uh and when you know the well [ __ ] you
know there's a [ __ ] sexual subtext to
this that's like killing your girlfriend
or something
you know but they're going to do it
anyway but that's that's kind of kind of
cold-blooded they were and that goes
back to kind of like the d coral story
they're killing other people then they
try to kill each other
yeah because eventually that [ __ ] will
come back right and that's what you do
that's what you're dealing with here
yeah mango says bronson is the melon
farmer yeah
yeah
that was the melon farmer
[Laughter]
majestic
that was a good movie though yeah i
liked it
like i said i remember seeing that one
when i was younger you could see that's
where they ripped off all the john wick
[ __ ] i just want my dog back around just
it's because of my dog
well this is he just trying to get the
melons
trying to get those melons out of the
ground i mean i understand the john wick
thing more though because yeah if you
killed my dog or my cat yeah i would
totally like haunt you to the end of the
earth sorry and like tear your [ __ ]
head off and [ __ ] down your neck that's
what i would do but uh don't touch his
melons
[Laughter]
but yeah so we're gonna talk about mr
majestic uh the melon farmer
tomorrow
uh but yeah so this movie uh again a lot
of charles bronson's uh old movies are
free on youtube yeah uh with ads so you
can go and watch them and this one is
like really really good at this one ten
out of ten i recommend it ten out of ten
it's it's classic you gotta see it yeah
it's a must-see
yeah so we might be on a charles bronson
kick for a while so we'll we'll see how
i got they sent me all the death wishes
too on on blu-ray yeah
so we gotta get to those too michael
winner directed those as well same
director as uh as the mechanic okay all
right so uh that'll do it for today
again uh gonna be talking about mr
majestic tomorrow so we'll be back
tomorrow at 5 p.m eastern standard time
because we're changing the time up all
of the live streams are going to be at 5
pm in case you weren't here earlier
because it was just easier for everyone
involved uh so yeah thanks for dropping
by today everybody and we'll see you
guys again tomorrow
bye